that's right I'm in a t-shirt that's
freaking you all out it should be or
this is not a movie review is not a
trailer review it's one of those to ever
see something where you're like that is
so cool I wish I could tell more people
about it that's exactly what happened to
me and then I was like I'll have a
youtube channel
I'm totally gonna tell my fans about
this because they would love this so
here you are
prepare to be informed and before we get
started on this video I'm going to tell
you that this video is brought to you by
loot crate for those of you don't know
what loot crate is all seven of you it's
a monthly subscription service you pay
money and then every month they send you
a crate that's a theme but no one knows
what's in the crate you open it up you
get cool nerdy stuff joy yeah I guess
loot crate likes it when I talk about
Star Wars that's cool before you do that
you got to hear it because this is the
point of this video I don't know about
you guys but me personally I have been
waiting day in day out for years
literally years for the original
unaltered Star Wars trilogy to come out
on blu-ray I figured they were gonna do
it before the force awakens comes out
and sure enough new blu-rays hit was
like oh I just free skins of the
blu-rays we already have this special
edition with all the alterations that we
already knew we've come to know like
great oh shooting first Vader yelling
nerd when he picks up the Emperor it's
all [ __ ] so at this point I had to
accept the fact that it wasn't happening
like it's Disney's not gonna bring it I
don't did it Fox still has distribution
rights to it they're not going to did no
one's going to do it we have to take
matters into our own hands so at the
phase of acceptance that is looking
online for other options I found
something called Star Wars despecialized
edition guys it exists it's not official
it's a fan project it's a fan edit but
it's one of those things where I heard
about there's a really cool YouTube
video explaining how this was done
ultimately spearheaded by this guy named
harm me like Peter harming or harm I
don't know what a username is and what
an actual name is on the internet these
days I'm just gonna call him harm II
he's the one who has gotten this project
together but you really do get the
feeling that it's a collaborative effort
among a few people which is the original
trilogy unaltered as it was in the
theatrical release originally brought to
blu-ray brought to hi-def this videos
cool it shows how they just Frankenstein
like we took a high-def version of that
and then spliced it in with a version of
that it just they had to Frank and [ __ ]
this thing to get it done but it's done
like there is their high def
versions of the original Star Wars
trilogy that exists online put a link
below to that video because that videos
super it's just fascinating to see that
kind of passion go into a project for a
trilogy that you just so loved and at
that point you're like why doesn't it
officially exist I just don't know I was
originally going to title this video
when fans do it better than
professionals because that's really the
case in point here these fans who just
had a passion to get something done did
what what the might of Disney and Fox
before it what they can't do how on
earth can these empires not do what
these fans apparently can do
I mean Disney said in a release are like
we want to do it but you know the
original prints they're not what they
used to be and it's gonna take some work
if it ever gets done ever I'm
paraphrasing right there but that was
basically the gist of what they said so
what so this Harmy guy and a bunch of
fans on the I guess their website is
original trilogy com they create
something that one of the biggest
studios in the industry just can't do
and I watch these things and they are
awesome like it's so cool to see in
blu-ray quality Han just blow grito away
did I saw it and on the forums of
original trilogy com there are people
who just dedicate their time to like
making blu-ray covers for these or a
bunch of different covers you can just
download them and print them out put
them in a blu-ray case and then burn
this and then boom now you have your
original trilogy on blu-ray no thanks to
any big studio nope just fans who did it
who did what Studios can't do now I
don't know about you guys I know hacking
and torrenting it's a big thing I am NOT
one for torrents I'm a big advocate of
paying what you get and getting paid for
what you put out you know that's the
total that's what we call the economy
but the reason I'm okay with this is
there are a couple of reasons first of
all he kind of does have an honor system
where he's like alright I download these
versions if you have bought the blu-ray
because they should get paid for it but
if you have paid for Star Wars you
should get the best version of Star Wars
out there so hey here you go the
despecialized edition and this product
this fan project doesn't exist anywhere
in the world there are no high-def
versions of Star Wars the original
trilogy unaltered that exists in the
world which in that is technically a fan
project so at that point you should
watch it
it's excellent cuz it's a point of this
video
wanted to tell you guys about this do
you specialize edition because I didn't
know about it until like a couple weeks
ago and then I found out about it I'm
like what rock what rock was i under
have no idea I don't know how I didn't
know about this but now I do and you
should do because Star Wars fans should
just know so when I knew I knew you had
to know and at that point we're all just
informed now we can just enjoy I figure
I should get this to you before the
force awakens comes out for people who
are really holding out like I want to
say the original trilogy dammit
unaltered for force awakens well here
you go that's my video like I said this
video is brought to you by loot crate if
you put in promo code Jeremy John's you
saved yourself 10% which is always great
it's great to save money when you're
getting cool nerdy [ __ ] just be sure to
do it in time for the December crate you
have until the 19th to get in your promo
code and subscribe to loot crate for the
December crate think of it as one day
after the force awakens comes out and
it's too late now I don't know what's
going to be in the December crate but I
do know the theme is galaxies galaxy
theme so yeah it's the month of the
release of the force awakens and loot
crate has a galaxy theme guys gonna let
you know if there is a time the time is
now it's gonna be some star which I
don't know they're gonna be stars up in
there I feel like there should bake so
Star Wars the original trilogy D
specialize have you seen it what did you
think about it if you have I don't know
it almost like negates the point of this
video so hey the figures around me can
you name them all like that guy right
there
awesome franchise whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more